بعد اربعه اشهر فقط من اعلانها ان فيروس
كورونا لم يعد يمثل حاله طوارئ صحيه
عالميه منظمه الصحه العالميه تنبه مجددا
من اتجاهات مثيره للقلق لفيروس كوفي 19
فيروس يصيبه ويعيد اصابه الملايين من
الاشخاص حاليا اولئك الاكثر عرضه للاصابه
بمرض شديد عليهم تلقي جرعه معززه واضافيه
من اللقاح
تقديرات منظمه الصحه العالميه تشير الى ان
مئات الالاف من الاشخاص حول العالم يضطرون
الى دخول المستشفى اثراء اصابتهم بالفيروس
خصوصا في دول اسيا والشرق الاوسط التي
تسجل وفيات بسببه في اوروبا تزداد حالات
دخول وحدات العنايه المركزه تقديرات قد
تكون اقل بكثير من الواقع بسبب عدم تبليغ
الدول عن حالات الاصابه
43 دوله فقط تبلغ المنظمه عن الوفيات
الناجمه عن كوفيد وع شرون دوله فقط ترسل
اليها المعلومات بشان الحالات التي تستدعي
دخول المستشفيات
تدعو المنظمه الى تلقي جرعات معززه او
اضافيه من اللقاح ضد متحوره
سريعه الانتشار لكنها تحذر ايضا من متحوره
فرعيه اخرى من اوميكرون او جي فاصل خمسه
تزداد انتشارا حاليا